the people who votes exception of this
is yes it was partly about brexit brexit
was a way of kind of um I I it was
important to a lot of people but I think
it was also the thing that sort of
tipped people over from realizing that
actually maybe they weren't really labor
voters but when they looked to what they
actually value now they saw the world
maybe they were really conservatives and
brexit enabled them to kind of recognize
that it's the end of an era you know the
the last 20 25 years of doing things is
coming to an end and people are you know
they're responding in different ways but
I think a lot of people feel that the
state is the biggest is ever been we
can't continue to see the state growing
and growing and growing and you know
what we're seeing is that you know this
collectivism the statism has been
reinforced by you know the bailouts from
the crash by the the lifestyle polls six
imposed by climate climate politics and
then by the pandemic and all of that has
reinforced the sense that you know
statism is the right way to go
government telling you what to do is the
right way to go and we've got to stop
that state is bigger than it's ever been
in this country
you know government rules influence over
your own behavior has become stronger
and stronger and it must stop in the
free Society you've got to call hold to
this
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm Constance
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today was
Britain's Chief negotiator with the
European Union during The brexit Saga
Lord David Frost welcome to trigonometry
great to be here thanks for having me it
is really good to have you here we're
going to get into all the issues in the
conversation before we do though uh
we've got a lot of people abroad who may
not know who you are tell everybody who
are you what has been your journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us yeah um so
um I spent much of my early life as a
diplomat professional Diplomat for UK
government
um so civil servants I I worked as the
foreign officers director for EU Affairs
lead on trade Affairs that that sort of
thing I got frustrated with being a
civil servant and not being able to say
what I think so I went off to run a big
trade Association for a bit Scotch
whiskey Association which a lot of
people say is the the Great job in the
world and sadly I only did it for three
years until Boris Johnson asked me to
become his uh foreign policy EU advisor
when he was from secretary and then as
as prime minister and that's how I ended
up doing the um the brexit negotiations
coming in when everything seemed to have
um uh got stuck I was for a Time
thereafter a minister in the
embarrassist government until I stepped
down at the end of last year over uh
because I wasn't able to support the uh
the the the prospect of another lockdown
uh over covered so that's that's our own
heart uh although we didn't step down
from anything uh but David uh in the
interest of full disclosure for our
audience uh you and I were speaking and
uh you mentioned that you'd watched or
listened to our interview with Matt
Goodwin who we have a lot of time for in
this show and as we were speaking about
the future the conservative party you
said that you had some different
thoughts about out all of that so what
are they
so I think you know the politics has
changed over the last uh sort of 10
years or so and as many people have said
it isn't just about economics anymore
it's it's about culture and you know
shorthand wokism though I hate the words
yeah I hated politics I don't see how a
past participle can become an abstract
noun just to reacts against that but
um uh so so it's got more complicated
and you know what I hear
um people like Matt and others saying is
that it is a possible position for the
conservative party to be in to be sort
of anti-wokan culture but quite statist
and left-wing on economic policy because
we've taken in red wall seats and you
know people who used to vote in labor
and I think my view is that's a fallacy
uh it's a fallacy of two reasons one
because people who vote conservative
think one should assume they actually
want conservative policies until it's
it's kind of proved otherwise
second I think the the the the the
choice these are different kinds of
choices the choice between sort of
wokism and non-wokism if you like is the
kind of political choice you know I I
happen to think one is better than the
other but it's basically about your
world view and how you want Society to
run the choice between do you have free
market economic policies or do you have
more status to economic policies is a
real world thing we know in the real
world free market pulses tend to reduce
more Prosperity more growth better
outcomes than others so if you if you
just look at this as a political thing
and say you know our the way politics
has evolved means that it's sensible for
us as a conservative party to take on
left-wing policies you're actually
condemning yourself to ideological and
actual defeat because you're choosing an
economy that isn't going to growl as
fast and people in Auckland like that so
that's why I think politics about
persuasion politics is about encouraging
people to
um you know kind of take on your
worldview and we should be standing up
for free market liberal policies focused
on growth focused on productivity
focused on the productive capacity of
this country I'm persuading people they
are the best pulses and that oh we're
beginning to do that now actually but
isn't the problem David that the
conservatives had a huge majority in the
2019 general election because they
promised in their own words to get
brexit done which to be fair you did and
you have all these red wall seats who
aren't naturally conservative therefore
you have MPS representing these people
who want more left-wing policies because
they're more economically disadvantaged
thus creating imbalance in the party
because if the MP for
a red wall seat doesn't represent their
constituents and their desires they're
going to lose their seat and they're
going to be out of a job but I so I
think
um the people who voted exception of
those is yes it was partly about brexit
brexit was a way of kind of um I I it
was important to a lot of people yeah
rightly so but I think it was also the
thing that sort of tipped people over
from realizing that actually maybe they
weren't really labor voters they were
doing it for historical traditional
other reasons for when they look to what
they actually valued now they saw the
world maybe they were really
conservatives and brexit enabled them to
kind of recognize that which you know we
shouldn't forget that Mrs Thatcher won a
lot of red wall seats in 1983 she held
on to them in 1987. it's not quite as
new as some people say that we've we've
had these these supporters and she won
them with an appeal to uh to free market
running your own life
um freeing yourself from the shackles of
State Housing state benefits people
telling you want to do all the time and
I think that appeal is is just as strong
nowadays and we we need to lean into it
and bring people into that support group
not not be embarrassed about it I
completely agree with you but if you
look at what the conservative policies
have been over the last couple of years
as they're not telling people what to do
in no State involvement I mean yeah we
vote I mean the government voted
conservative they got left of corbyn
didn't they in many ways
I'm the last person to defend the
economic record of the last last couple
of years I think it's you know it's well
known that I I resign in part because of
it I think you know we we are
people made the comparison with the
1970s quite often and I think one of the
reasons that's correct is that it's the
end of an era you know the the last 20
25 years of doing things is coming to an
end and people are you know they're
responding in different ways but I think
lots of people feel that and you know
what we're seeing is that you know this
collectivism the statism has been
reinforced by you know the bailouts for
the crap from the crash by the the
lifestyle politics imposed by climate uh
climate politics and then by the
pandemic and all of that has reinforced
the sense that you know statism is the
right way to go government telling you
what to do is the right way to go and
we've got to stop that the state is
bigger than it's ever been in this
country uh you know government rules
influence over your own behavior has
become stronger and stronger and it must
stop in the free Society you've got to
call hold to this at some point you do
but isn't the problem as well when
you've got a population who become used
to the big state
that the moment you start taking it away
You're Gonna threaten you know your own
chance of being reelected because all of
a sudden you're going to become the mean
nasty Tories who are only interested in
big business and let's be fair has Trump
no Trump sorry because trust made a bit
there's a slip
and then you've got Trust basically you
know with Bankers Bankers bonuses Etc
well I mean I ideally you'll be doing
this at the start of a four or five
years term and for reasons we know about
that that hasn't been possible there's
only two years or so left
um but I you know I still think you've
got to do the right things if we if
we're going to go down to defeats let's
at least do it having had the argument
done what we said was the right thing
tried to to persuade people rather than
half-heartedly doing things we don't
really believe in in the belief that it
might keep everybody happy people can
recognize intellectual confidence and
authenticity I think and it appeals to
to people so let's let's lean into that
let's do the things we believe in and
believe will work and I think they will
work I I think you know two years is
long enough to start seeing some of the
results of this but we have to have
intellectual confidence we have to start
talking about
um you know the role of profits the role
of a normal interest rate in a
capitalist economy the things that make
it work can be honest about this not not
be embarrassed about it are you tired of
using bulky old wallets giving you a
bulge where you don't want it to be my
old wallet was massive so it brought all
the ladies to the yard which was a huge
distraction and got in the way of my
esteemed work on trigonometry reg
wallets have an incredible solution for
you this is mine Sleek stylish and with
an industrial look to it can fit 12
cards with cash on the back using a clip
like this one or a strap we've got one
for the whole team I've got one Francis
has one even our producer Anton has one
but he's from Liverpool so he flogged
his on the black market the great thing
about Ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee which means if you
want you can have only one wallet for
the rest of your life Rich are so
confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallets that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days and that's not all for every
dollar you spent on the ridge wallets
website you'll be entered into a
competition to win a brand new upgraded
Ford Bronco or if you can't drive like
Francis then you can win 75 000 in cash
winners will be announced in October so
get spending because we're just such
great guys are going to give you 10 off
and free worldwide shipping and returns
to take advantage of this incredible
offer go to ridge.com forward slash
trigger that's ridged dot com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
David I think you you put your finger on
something that is obviously very
important particularly in terms of your
comparison with Thatcher and I imagine
there's someone who used to be this
country's Chief negotiator with the EU
even though you're very softly spoken
you must know how to carry a big stick
too however in the current prime
minister's situation it must be
extraordinarily difficult to yes she
speaks confidently and softly at the
same time but how do you carry a stick
when you've got no mandate whatsoever
that is is difficult I I wouldn't say
we've got no mandate because you know
that is the way our system works it's
not the first time the prime minister's
changed midterm and people accept that's
that's part of the way the system works
I think you know you've just got to have
this trust the team have got to have
intellectual confidence and and say you
know be honest about the the mistakes
were made in the last couple of years be
honest about where things have gone
wrong be clear that things are going to
a different direction say judges in a
couple of years if you don't like it
obviously there is there is another
route but to be clear make sure people
understand what uh what we're trying to
do and why and what the the goal is I
think that's the crucial thing at the
moment people are just not being talked
to honestly for so long about things and
we can change that I agree with you on
that I I really do hope we change that
um and I suppose this morning you came
in you were quite chipper uh you uh
we're as we're recording this it'll be a
few days before it goes out uh the
chancellor the new Chancellor was just
announcing I mean I don't think many
people would have expected
um who were the general public who are
not you know obsessed with politics like
the three of us would have expected that
in this current climate the thing that
the government would be doing is
slashing taxes abolishing the top rate
of tax next year and all of the other
things that are now happening you must
be delighted yeah I think it's
absolutely the right thing to do
um we must get things we must get the
economy on to a different path we've got
to change expectations yes it's going
you know there's going to be a an uplift
in borrowing in the short run but we
must get people thinking that we are
trying to improve the productive
capacity of this economy we've got to
get investors people look at this
country saying yeah the Brits get get it
they can't do everything straight away
but they understand what needs to be
done and they're getting on the right
path and the there needs to be that sort
of psychological shock change of
expectations and belief things can get
get better and I think that's what
um the chance of trying to deliver today
I actually believe that you know in the
capitalist economy you need you need
interest rates that are above zero I
think they're going to have to go a lot
further not just to control inflation
but because that's how the economy works
um we probably are going to have to see
a lower pound because that's that we
need to be on a different forward curve
and to support the economy is right to
do a bit of borrowing and tax cut so
demand doesn't collapse and I think this
is a perfectly rational Way Forward
um and all the sort of world weary
economists who are out there saying what
about boring what about this what about
that is irresponsible what are the
treasury officials think of it all I
just think that is that is
they're still talking a story that is
irrelevant to the challenges that face
the country after brexit and in this new
world and well I do agree with you but I
am one of those not economists but
certainly World wary in terms of the
amount of borrowing but I think we have
to distinguish between different types
of borrowing if you're borrowing on a
credit card to go and have a a night out
that's one thing if you're borrowing to
build a business that's completely
different and this brings me to the two
issues that Francis and I talk about all
this all the time which is we've
borrowed to pay people to stay at home
before that we borrowed to pay Bankers
to stay afloat what about the housing
crisis what about infrastructure in this
country because I've got no problem
borrowing more money to do those things
to create jobs and to get the economy
moving
are we going to get those two issues
solved with just cutting taxes and
allowing some people would argue money
just to accumulate at the top with no
productive activity being generated it
can only be the first step you know this
is about changing expectations and
making people believe that things can be
better and the economy can improve I
think the government has announced today
some some improvements to or at least
prospects some improvements to
infrastructure uh getting through
quicker let's see what that looks like
it is really important obviously the
housing market is a massive massive
problem in this this country and
um you know it's a huge part of the
productivity problem I think not being
able to move houses is obviously part of
part of that we're going to have to
build more houses there's there's no two
ways about around that that we're going
to have to build houses in places where
people don't want houses to be built and
we're going to have to find a way of
making that that possible I think it is
more possible than people believe but
it's going to have to be done and you
know I hope the government is going to
take this on in the Enterprise I'm not
hearing forgive me but um I'm hearing
we're going to have to as opposed to
that's what's going to happen I do you
believe it's going to happen I believe
it is going to happen actually I don't
necessarily think it's going to happen
like tomorrow because sequencing is
important and getting people used to
ideas is important and I think one of
the the problems we've had actually one
of the consequences of this sort of
collectivism over the last 20 years is
that people have not been prepared for
the scale of the challenge that there
has to come we've not talked about how
Market's economies work we've not talked
about what that means for your own
individual prospects how you have to
prepare yourself how you have to skill
uh you know how all this sort of thing
we've just not talked about it so you
can't I think suddenly land people with
a million things that are a completely
different world view and expect people
to put up with it we have to allow some
time for persuasion for getting people
used to ideas for testing things and
showing that actually it isn't so bad
maybe when you do this hopefully
fracking for example is going to be one
of those things and and gradually change
the debate so you shouldn't rush at
everything I think the crucial thing is
also to have a really convincing
Manifesto for the next election is based
on a real story of which you can get a
real mandate to do some actually
difficult things and some of that you've
got to prepare for you can't just do it
all straight away but isn't also the
problem as well David is that you know a
lot you know you get a lot of these
conservative voters who are nimbies
not in my backyard yeah and also you
know a lot of them own property you're
essentially if you're going to build
large swabes of housing to solve this
crisis and it is a crisis you're
essentially devaluing their assets
aren't you
well that is a that is a risk I mean you
know there is so much
um uh pressure in the housing market
particularly in Southern England that uh
you know it take it's going to take a
lot to to sort of devalue uh people's
assets over a sustained period I think
you know we're really just talking about
keeping a lid on things and hoping that
you know inflation and growth you know
kind of enable people to catch up over
time uh so I think people are more
worried than they need be probably about
this but but I think you know people
like me people you know who have
benefited from the boom uh the illusory
boom actually in many ways of the last
20 years
um have got to accept that you know we
have an intergenerational responsibility
yeah and part of that is getting more
houses built even if there's there's a
cost I just think that is part of the
story that has to be told to me it's one
of the biggest problems with our society
because we talk about workers are more
progressivism or however you want to
describe it but how can you possibly
expect young people to be conservative
or to adopt conservative values when
they literally have nothing to conserve
they rent a a one bedroom flat in
Hackney for the best part of two grand a
month yeah well I I I I couldn't agree
with you more
um you know the we we have to
there's been so much so many imbalances
for so long in in asset prices in the
aftermarket housing market generally
um is going to take a long time to to
unwind this the pressures are so great I
mean it's you you're already there's a
huge benefit from setting up a business
in northern England buying a house in
Northern English already a lot lot
cheaper than in boom areas the South yet
people don't do it the pressures are
still to come to this house it's going
to take a lot to to reverse that but you
have to start somewhere and you have to
start giving people a a feeling that you
know if they work if they do save
actually it's a worthwhile thing to do
and not completely pointless thing to do
which is is how people feel at the
moment I think yeah that's not untrue
and Francis and I again as trigonometry
becomes a small business we have staff
we have we pay tax all of these things
you know you go to America and you kind
of realize like it's not that easy to
run a business in Britain it's not that
easy to do these things because there
are a lot of taxes to pay there's lots
of rules to follow there's lots of boxes
to take all of these things so I get
that but David um this is what I want to
ask you because a lot of the people who
watch our show uh in from the UK will be
those red wool uh people some of whom
will absolutely agree with you I can
think of several of uh supporters who
already will be on your side but there
will be a lot of people also who as
we've talked about uh we've had a long
period of time now where if there's a
problem
government's answer
what is the economic argument at its
core that you're making about the free
market the the and or you know reducing
regulation reducing taxes why is that
better how does that work how does the
you mentioned the economy this is how it
works explain that at a very basic level
for us why is your view of how the
economy should be managed better
that people make better choices for
themselves they they obviously you need
a a framework and the state sets the
framework but basically people know
better themselves what they want to do
and how they want to live their lives
and where they want to spend their money
and what they want to spend it on
um then uh the government does and where
the government tries to do it it tends
to get it wrong it imposes its own
judgments on people it makes them do
things they wouldn't otherwise choose to
do it accepts it sets up a a single view
of the good society which you're forced
to buy into and you have to live by the
government rules and I I think that
historically has been shown not to work
where it's been tried now you know when
nobody's going to try in the extreme
forms in this country although you know
during the pandemic there were there
were some quite extreme things happening
but if you allow people to make their
own decisions you know accumulate money
for themselves and their their families
live their lives as they they they want
to they'll make better decisions they'll
invest they'll become more prosperous
that's the fundamental core I think of
this I hear you and from where I'm
sitting the obvious and very easy way to
attack your argument is to say but what
about the people who can't help
themselves what about the disabled what
about the people who are chronically ill
every time we reduce the size of the
state yes you know we unleash the the
Brilliance of billionaires and
millionaires in this country to build
businesses even if we that charitable to
your argument but the people who really
suffer are the people living in deprived
communities people who are like I say
rely on the NHS to survive people who
are disabled and mentally or physically
all of these people surely will suffer
as we reduce the size of the state would
be that argument
well I everybody would agree that the
state should you know be generous to to
people who can't work for for whatever
reason it is
um the problem is that
um we have over the years and got a
state system that is is much more
generous than that and that's that's
kind of undermining support for us under
under for a lot of people the Universal
Credit system for example you can claim
Universal Credit
um if you're you know on the average
wage and you know in what sense is that
a kind of benefit for people who can't
help themselves they see big complex
system that funnels money from one part
to the economy to to another and in so
doing it's undermining support for State
transfers as a whole is making people
who have no need to be dependent upon
state of course we must help people who
can't help themselves
um the government's actually not very
good at uh it seems to me in many ways
and focusing on that would be would be a
better thing to do you know people
people have forgotten I think that the
state is the biggest is ever been we
can't continue to see the state growing
and growing and growing
um because we think it's the right thing
to do we you have to draw a line
somewhere and focus the state back down
on its core tasks under Tony Blair the
state was you know five percent GDP
smaller than now everyone seems to think
Tony Blair time was quite a good time
and you know people who I don't agree
with politically quite quite liked it
and you know life went on even though
the state was a lot smaller you can get
it smaller you can focus down on this on
the the core tasks I I agree with you
that it does need to be smaller because
at the moment it's economically
unsustainable and it's not really a
conversation that we want to have and
the big elephant in the room to me is
the NHS which is becoming more and more
unfit for purpose when see how much
money is being plowed into it and yet
the ordinary person struggles to get a
GP appointment
the waiting list I don't know however
many millions it goes seems to go up by
a million every week or something
ridiculous like that and people waiting
to get cancer appointments checkups
it doesn't work does it it does it
doesn't or it works in a very sort of
crude
um inefficient fashion and that's what
you get when you you know you've got one
half million people and a budget of 160
billion a year all run from the center
inevitably you get these these outcomes
and I I mean I'm encouraged that I think
for the first time in my political life
I suppose we've we're beginning to hear
people say actually this isn't working
very well I don't like it that I can't
get my GP I don't like if that was a
waiting list every time you know when I
go into hospital I see a different
person every day they lose my papers I'm
not confident they're not giving me you
know they're giving me the right drugs
you hear this kind of all the time from
people's day-to-day experience
and there's only so long I think that
people can hold the day-to-day
experience in parallel with the the sort
of religious belief about the the system
in the end one undermines the other and
I hope we're beginning to to see that I
think actually also people have you know
lots of people got experience of the
European systems now whether they live
in Europe or have visited it they've
seen what it's like to get treatment
somewhere other than the NHS and they
don't think it's that bad necessarily
and I think it's beginning to kind of
permeate through so the problem is that
you can't change the NHS overnight uh
you know it is the task a generation
really to change this this monolith
you've got to start somewhere you've got
to stop adding new tasks you should take
off some of the sort of frivolities that
people should pay for themselves and I
think gradually you've got to try and
bring in some sort of Market
Insurance elements out the margins
probably first and get it working in a
more functional way but that's going to
take 20 years if you started today I
think and that's why people shy away
um what do you mean by the for volatives
David what are we talking about with the
worth of volatiles well uh sort of
Lifestyle surgery maybe you know I don't
know some people say IVF for example
people should pay for themselves I mean
I think the debates we had about that
but I think all at the moment all the
pressure is the other way that you know
new kind of things get added into
NHS treatment all the time and
um you know again you've got to draw the
line somewhere or not I'm not making a
direct comparison here but if you look
at like veterinary services for example
completely private service obviously and
no suggesting we should do that but
there is no shortage you can get to see
a vet coming tomorrow because the market
works and in the NHS we have no Market
meaningfully at all the only uh sort of
sorting system is by queue and that's
that's what happens so you've got to try
and bring elements of rationality into
it I think I'm and we say to those
people go look if we do that what we're
going to become is effectively the
United States where you know people are
essentially made bankrupt every time
they get diagnosed with cancer cancer
treatments cost tens of thousands of
dollars if not hundreds of thousands how
do we stop that from happening so I
think that there is always this
um
artificial comparison made between
um as if the only two models are our
model and the US model and
um you know it it bedevils the debate we
have on this actually you know people
need to get the we are the outlier
hardly anybody runs their Health Service
like we do with virtually everything
being delivered by government the only
countries that do all the Scandinavians
and the Irish much smaller countries
where you don't have this sort of
massive monolith problem that we do in
the UK there's 10 times as big the norm
in an advanced country is to have some
sort of social insurance system some
quite a lot of
competition quite a lot of private
provision in the system and a lot more
patience and consumer choice that is the
international Norm across Europe and we
could go there so let's pray that down
what does that actually mean a social
insurance system because I'm sure
there's people watching and listening to
this thinking what what like Bupa is
that a social insurance system well not
really because it's kind of outside the
system altogether what we're seeing at
the moment I think uh and we've seen
quite a lot in the last year or two is
that we're getting two systems in this
country we've got the NHS that doesn't
work and then you've got to completely
private system which totally separated
from it there's no sort of tax benefit
or any other kind it's entirely for
people who've got the ability to to pay
for it however you do get treatment
quickly
um the way the European mostly European
systems work and they're all kind of
different so there's no single model but
that there is a a sort of compulsory
Insurance element you know you join
maybe one of a number of insurance
schemes you can choose the level at
which you you you go into these schemes
um quite a lot of the provision is
contracted for by these schemes or
sometimes by the government private
clinics private doctors whatever but the
whole system is backed up by the
government it's still largely free at
the point of use but it's not run by the
government and there's much more
efficiency in the way treatment happens
and you know you simply you know apart
from the special case after the pandemic
you simply don't get these sort of
massive waiting lists in many European
countries that that we do here and if
people understood that I think they'd be
more well that is actually something
just as inside because I want to move on
but that is something I think people in
this country really don't understand is
how how extraordinary it is that as a
wealthy country you have a Healthcare
System where you have to wait you have
to wait at all I mean in Russia or
Ukraine or countries that I've grown up
in the notion that you would wait for an
appointment to see your doctor
but it yeah it's absurd yes it's absurd
I agree it's completely absurd so I mean
I hear you on that one uh I want to move
on though David because
uh coming right back to the beginning of
our conversation and Matt Goodwin
sitting here one of the things that he
talked about and I hear Nigel farage
talking about this quite extensively
essentially
Nigel farage's argument is
because of what's happening with
immigration now
the people who will fill the space that
he's vacated will be in his words I
think far less Pleasant to the
chattering classes than even he was yeah
and I think it's fair to say that when
people voted to quote unquote Take Back
Control of the borders
they did not vote for immigration to
increase as it did under your former
boss and they certainly did not vote for
thousands of people to come into this
country illegally every month
what is what is the new prime minister
going to do about this so I think
um
is really important uh first of all to
um that the state works properly and
this is one of the areas where it needs
to to work properly so although I'm
often caricatured as a kind of crazed
free marketeer of some kind actually I
think it is really important to see the
two things in parallel the the private
economy the market economy needs to work
in a free market way but the state also
needs to work properly and be properly
funded and that means things like
controlling the borders properly it
means proper Law and Order police on
streets a justice system that works and
prisons that aren't a sort of you know
disgrace frankly to a civilized society
it means the benefits working properly
in the way that we were talking about
earlier so you know there definitely is
a big role for a state uh the problem is
it's again it's taking on more and more
kind of frivolous tasks the whole time
getting distracted from his core duties
and that's what that's what it's got to
do so that's the the context and um
on the immigration thing I mean
I I
think immigration must come down uh is
not
sort of straightforward to look at this
year on year because you don't control a
number of people who leave the country
for one thing so they're always kind of
the you know the the graph will always
um vary year on year it's the overall
trend you've got to look at the truth is
our economy has
um
benefited from or has has we've
developed an economic model has been
based on lots of cheap labor from Europe
for the last 20 25 years you can't turn
that off overnight
um I don't think we should turn that off
overnight uh given there's so many other
economic problems going going on but I
do think we have to set trajectory that
is down and be clear that it's going to
go down and set that in a in a credible
way and the problem again at the moment
is that over the last year we've talked
tough about immigration but after the
numbers have you know if anything gone
up I think it's not entirely clear
because of course not every European
would have shown up in the system
beforehand
um but nevertheless it remains high and
it has to come down we have to move to a
different model where
business adjusts to the fact that there
isn't an indefinite supply of free labor
and invests in the people they've got
but that is going to take a bit of time
okay that's the first part but the other
part and this is something I can tell
you something you already know illegal
immigration pisses people off like
nothing else and it pisses people like
me off who are first generation
immigrants came to this country followed
the process a process that isn't always
Pleasant or fair or cheap or whatever
right but I don't think I think the one
of the defining features of this country
is the sense of fairness and I don't
understand
how people in in politics seem to not
understand or how crucial addressing
that issue is because and it's not
because contrary to what people like to
say that it's about racism or xenophobia
whatever it is I think it's about
fairness people don't feel that anyone
should come into this country illegally
totally agree and we have thousands of
people coming in and we have no idea who
they are as well there's a security
Dimension to this there's a fairness
Dimension I mean you can look at it in
many different ways how first of all how
is it even possible that what six years
on from brexit
there are people coming here in in boats
from war-torn France how is that
happening so I mean it is an incredibly
complicated question and I think Boris
Boris Johnson got blamed unfairly
actually for not caring about this
problem I know he he really did try and
had meetings sort of every two or three
days on the subject for lots of time I
was there in number 10 it was not for
want of trying or thinking this was not
a problem it was because it was an
extremely intractable problem and there
is the Practical problem that you know
when people are coming over in a small
unseaworthy boat you you know kind of a
common Humanity means you've got to
handle them in a in a certain way the
French won't take them back therefore
you end up having to sort of bring them
into the UK where they're then
surrounded by the panoply of
um uh sort of legal protections judicial
reviews the uh you know amateurish and
slow way we run our Asylum system that
produces an incentive to to come here
and and risk it so there's lots of
things that that need changing
um I think the you know the the
government is going to have to get more
robust uh on this I think it's going to
have to say you know if you come here uh
illegally you don't get the right to
stay you have to work out what the
consequences of of that are and I think
it's going to have to take on the echr
issue the echr
um conventional human rights is is part
of the is the ultimate reason why there
are so many legal challenges so many
um problems uh in the legal framework
that we've got and I think we're going
to have to try and cut through that in
some way in the next couple of years I
can't see how we can solve this problem
without doing that
hey Francis do you like ideas cool side
do my favorite idea was getting that
Chinese Takeaway last night I was
talking about important ideas that
matter so was I the lemon chicken was
well there's the Battle of ideas oh is
that a competition between the best
takeaways because I know which one would
definitely win right if I promise to buy
you some lemon chicken will you shut up
and do this ad with me sir yes sir the
Battle of oint is is a free speech
Festival which is held in church house
in London on the 15th and 16th of
October they have a wide and diverse
range of speakers from across the
political Spectrum who debate the most
important issues facing our society I'll
be there in conversation about my book
and immigrants love letter to the West
and Francis is doing a panel as well
whatever issue you're most passionate
about you'll find it discussed at the
Battle of ideas they have panels that
will debate everything from Big Tech
education the Arts and Free Speech plus
the audience gets a chance to ask the
panel questions as well like what's
their favorite child click on the link
in the description and use the code to
trigger tutu to get 13 off that's right
click on the link in the description use
the code trigger 2-2 and get 13 off
we'll see you at the Battle of ideas in
London oh and there's also a great
Chinese round
[Laughter]
like Nigel said that the problem is is
that if this problem if this issue isn't
being dealt with
then what you get is what I call you
know the Tommy Robinson Factor where you
get somebody unpleasant who comes along
points an issue like grooming gangs and
goes they're not doing anything they're
not listening to you they don't care
yeah but I do and I will yeah and that's
a real danger for that democracy 100
agree that's that's why it's so
important the you know the state gets
gets a grip on this and you know there
are lots of
there are lots of reasons why it doesn't
they're they're partly bureaucracy the
party kind of cultural I think the why
the police don't tackle some of these
these issues and and they go go quite
deep but you know you can't you can't
stop people caring about things and if
the government doesn't respond to their
concerns then other people will respond
to them and that's just the way it is
and government has to accept that
because
if let's say labor win the election
which is perfectly possible in the next
couple of years that could well happen I
mean they're going to be even worse at
dealing with this situation than
conservatives yeah I think so because
they don't have any of the sort of
presumptions about how these things
should work I mean they just will not
have the will to tackle it uh in any way
and we know you know a good chunk of the
the modern labor party the membership
not the sporters I think for the
membership you know don't really believe
in borders at all they don't really
believe in the nation state as a concept
uh at all and you know there's no way
they're going to be able to tackle this
I really fear for things actually in
those circumstances do you think that
this two-tier party system do you think
it's got a future because there's lots
of people making perfectly valid
criticisms about it David and going
who did the conservatives represent who
do labor represent
I I mean I think
every part is
um every country is sort of political
system is is determined by
um
stuff that's quite deep in the way the
country works and I don't think you can
just change bits of it without having
all kinds of unintended consequence I
mean the fixed term Parliament acts good
example of that where it was it was a
bit bolted on from a PR type system and
it never worked and in the end we've had
to get rid of it I I mean I think the
the advantages of our system so a short
version is yes I think it can and should
survive
um the advantage of it is that it forces
parties to be coalitions themselves they
can't become so ideological and you know
just just respond to a very small niche
of people they have to sort of have
these this sort of debates and the
single member constituency means people
don't get you know it's not possible to
get completely out of touch with what
people are thinking in the way that in
some of the European PR systems where
you're on a list and you never meet an
ordinary voter you just sort of lose
touch
so I think it you know every system has
the problems of its advantages but but I
think ours is the right one for us
because you do need
Fringe parties in many ways to hold the
bigger parties to account like the
brexit party really needed to hold the
conservative party's feet to the fire to
make sure that what people voted for was
inactive yeah it did and um you know but
I think that was a sort of freak
situation in some ways
um you know it destroys the conservative
party briefly in those European
elections in 2019 we're down to whatever
it was nine percent nationally
um but it was a freak situation the
Constitution was breaking down you know
a lot of the Norms had just were on hold
um but but you know ukip you know
arguably took enough out of the
conservative vote to
um Force the referendum uh when it was
announced in 2013 so so yeah they have a
functioning system but but I don't think
I still think it's better for democracy
to have you know a couple of big parties
that represent World Different World
Views the problem with sister's eyes
when you get two parties that think the
same thing about important issues like
climate change is the obvious example
recently or to a large extent the
pandemic then there's no debate that
that's the problem so they have got to
represent different views about things
properly right and uh well I was
actually going to move on to to Global
stuff but speaking of uh climate change
uh and Net Zero uh what is in your
opinion the future of that issue under
the current uh Tory regime
so I think
um you know I think is there going to be
a slash and burn we're going to abandon
Net Zero entirely I doubt it
um because it's pretty well embedded as
a as a Target now
um 2050
um but I do think that you know I
a lot of people think that we're rushing
at it too fast and doing it in a way
that you know makes no sense that just
deprives us of actual energy to power
our economy and you know going at it in
a way where
um government picks the route you know
and all this sort of stuff about heat
pumps and electric cars and all this
this kind of thing
um you know government picking winners
never works if you're going to do this
the rational way a bit of carbon tax and
just increase it a bit every year and
let the market sort out and what the
best way of doing it was
um I don't know whether we'll we'll do
that but I think we will see much more
focus on energy Security on energy cost
than on the so-called climate impact I
mean I just don't think we're in the
climate emergency so I don't think the
thing is as
urgent as people say the one emergency
we are in is the one that you referred
to because I think particularly in the
aftermath of the Russian invasion of
Ukraine
energy security food security and border
security these issues which we all
pretended were not issues for quite a
long time I think ideologically uh
they've now come to the fore uh and uh
the the current prime minister and we as
a country for for a long time are going
to have to reckon with all of this
um
the world is decoupling it's
de-globalizing uh how how best to
approach our role in that world for
Britain yeah I think we
you know it's it's the cliche you know
we lost an Empire we didn't find a role
now we've lost the European Union and
we're still looking around for a kind of
international role I I think we tend to
underplay ourselves as a as a country I
think people look at Britain in the from
the outside much more than we we really
100 I can promise you that when I speak
to people where I'm from about Britain
their view of Britain is much more they
see Britain and value it much higher
than than we do in this country yeah
that's my experience and you know when I
was a uh as a diplomat I think um you
know we are still a pretty big economy
we still stand for some important things
I think our you know the the
I think it should be about resilience to
a very large extent
um we're going to have to push up
defense spending we're going to have to
try and revive NATO properly as a sort
of serious security and defense
organization we've got things like the
orcas pact with the the Australians and
the indo-pacific tilts that I think is
going to be important as we we sort of
try and deter China I think we
you know one of the things that I find
people do react against a bit is you
know we can be a bit preachy about
things and I I kind of I don't like our
embassies going you know sort of endless
again on demonstrations about this and
that fashionable cause I think you know
you've got to look at the world as it is
bit and you know sometimes that means
dealing with people who you don't
necessarily like very much or approve of
everything they do but they've got stuff
that you need so you've got to that's
just the way the world is so a bit more
realism about the world a bit less
preachiness
um but you know a bit sort of standing
up for things that we we believe in I I
think Britain is a Force for good
um but we've got to put the money into
sharing that I would say and we that's
just beginning really this new this new
role yeah I agree with you we do need to
do that the problem is David is you look
at the kids coming out of universities
you know they
on the whole seem to be very skeptical
skeptical seem to be very anti-british
is constant focus on Empire and look you
know and as somebody who has just read a
little bit about it obviously we weren't
Angels but no Empire is you know people
think what the Ottomans were woke yeah
so the problem is is that we talk about
this and I think we can all agree on
that but you look at the younger
Generations coming through the
universities
and you look at people who are more on
the left in the labor party they think
completely differently I mean how how do
we unify this country yeah I think it is
a I mean it's gone along we've gone a
long way down this road uh that's the
problem
um and I think one of the the
consequences of
you know the fat people in their 20s 30s
maybe even 40s don't have a stake is in
society you know don't have a house
maybe defer having kids till they're a
bit late to this sort of thing is that
they they can sort of live in a world of
kind of illusions of you know how the
world is and how it works for a bit
longer than they used to to be able to
and that that is part of of what we're
seeing you know there's a kind of
um sort of fantasy world being created
about how it works and how we got here
and what is important to Western
civilization and advanced economy and
you know I actually think it's time for
the government and people like us to be
you know even more assertive about that
so I thought you know your your book
constant is great on this subject this
is this is what has made us this is what
is important in the western Society keep
telling yourself about it because
otherwise people start saying different
things but it's it's very difficult when
University like I said before is telling
these kids that we're evil when we're
wrong yeah
I it's gone very deeply and I you know
one of the this whole sort of um
assault on Western culture and history
and and so on one of the questions I
asked myself and I haven't heard people
answer is you know why is it happening
um you know there is
what has driven it how have we got to
this point
um and I see you know there are kind of
two answers I think one is that there's
a bunch of sort of cultural marxists you
know going through the institutions
trying to destroy Western Society in the
universities and so on and the other is
that this is just liberalism sort of
push to its Nth Degree as you knock over
wantaboo you look for another Taboo in
order to stop that looking
kind of absurd you have to create this
sort of alternative reality so that
things don't look absurd and there is
you know the sort of an emperor new
clothes thing can can survive and I
think that's actually more what we're
seeing because that's the kind of
liberalism
um social liberalism that you know kind
of started in the 60s uh in universities
in the intellectual clusters has just
been pushed and pushed and pushed so
that there are no taboos left and that
doesn't mean it was wrong to do what
happened in the 60s but it does mean
that sense for people have got to say
you're pushing this too far the world
isn't like this uh it's like this yeah
and and just be more honest about that
uh David I wish we could talk for longer
but we're not as good negotiators as you
said so the deal we did with the
builders across the road that they would
stop building for a while is now expired
and we're gonna have to ask you our
final question and wrap up
um what is the one thing that we're not
talking about that we really should be
so
I think it's it's not it's the subject
that we we are talking about bit but not
enough and it's about Devolution and the
union of this this country I think there
is
far too great an acceptance that
um the country has divided up or is
divided up into four different units
we're in a sort of Confederation because
it uh is kind of convenient to everybody
but it could be different
um and meanwhile we should let Scotland
and Wales kind of do their own thing and
not worry too much about this and you
know I think it's hard to get people in
England to kind of care about what's
happening in Scotland and increasingly
in Wales which seems to be going down
the same road now
um and I I think we've got to have an
honest conversation about you know where
Devolution has has taken us is
undermining the the kind of unity of
this nation states and you know you go
to Germany get France go to Italy they
would regard to the kind of debate we
have about the the you know the the
different components this country is
entirely bizarre but you know the idea
you could just detach and go a different
way
um would be quite wrong so I think we
need you know it's very difficult people
don't like
um every time you you sort of tell the
SNP or the Welsh labor party they can't
be like this you get this sort of
Tolerance of you know pushback but we've
got to how it start having this this
conversation again this is a unitary
nation state
Devolution is one thing and path to
Independence is a different thing and
you've got to start pulling it back
together again it was incredible to me
that
um we essentially devolved our travel
policy who could come in and out of the
country during the pandemic to The
Scholar Welsh governments who have seem
to be allowed to do their own thing
nobody thought that was what the
evolution was about and it shouldn't be
what it's about and we've got to pull
that back it will be very uncomfortable
but I think it needs to be done Lord
David Frost it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for coming on
the show thank you it's been great
enjoyed it and thank you guys for
watching and listening we will see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one or our show all of them go
at 7 pm UK time
what are you most proud of achieving
with the brexit negotiations and is
there anything you wish you could have
achieved but didn't
foreign
[Music]